je ne vous apprends rien si je vous dis
que les intelligences artificielles sont
de plus en plus doués dans des tas de
domaines que ce soit dans la médecine
avec watson dit bm qui est capable
d'ingurgiter 40 millions de documents en
15 secondes par la finance avec et
heures qui a permis d'économiser 150 1
millions de dollars de pertes en trois
semaines ou encore avec les voitures
autonomes de tesla qui permettent aux
utilisateurs de s'endormir au volant
l'intelligence artificielle nous montre
qu'elle sait aujourd'hui faire aussi
bien voire mieux que nous dans de
nombreux domaines et on pourrait croire
que les domaines artistiques ne sont pas
touchés parce qu'ils font appel à la
sensibilité et la créativité mais
pourtant il n'en est rien
la musique que vous écoutez à l'instant
est fait par une intelligence
artificielle et s'appelle ayvaz et c'est
la première intelligence artificielle à
recevoir des droits sacem
ce court métrage et la mise en image
d'un script écrit par une intelligence
artificielle et ses costumes
vous l'avez deviné ont été réalisés par
intelligence artificielle également
alors on pourrait penser que faire un
opéra c'est pas très différente tout ça
et pourtant aucune intelligence
artificielle ne peut le réaliser il faut
que je vous explique pourquoi
[Musique]
l'opéra est un art ancien mais c'est
surtout un art complexe voire même total
car c'est un art au carrefour de
nombreuses autres déjà il est à la
rencontre de deux arts qui saute aux
yeux et aux oreilles
ce sont la dramaturgie et la musique un
opéra c'est une histoire avec une
narration des personnages et le tout et
mise en musique avec un orchestre et des
chanteurs et chanteuses d'opéra qui sont
assez souvent exceptionnelles mais ce
n'est pas que ça c'est aussi une mise en
scène qui sublime le texte et la
performance des artistes et enfin ceux
ci des costumes des décors et tout un
travail de minutie autour de ces
éléments qui vont plonger l'audience
dans une esthétique mais bon on l'avait
en intro tout ça n'empêche pas une
intelligence artificielle d'en faire un
on pourrait imaginer qu'un jour un opéra
aussi puissent être créées par un
intelligence artificielle une
intelligence artificielle qui saurait
appuyé sur les bons boutons de notre
cerveau pour nous faire ressentir
exactement ce qu'elle veut nous
transporter plus loin que ce que
pourrait faire carmen ou la traviata
alors qu'est ce qui coince pour répondre
à cette question il faut déjà comprendre
ce qu'est une intelligence artificielle
symbos un peu fourre tout et souvent mal
utilisés
mais globalement c'est un ou une série
d'algorithmes et souvent c'est même plus
précisément un réseau de neurones sans
rentrer dans le détail c'est un réseau
auquel on donne un ensemble de données
qui les analyse et qui à partir de ces
données réalise sa version à lui c'est
comme ça que fonctionnent les
intelligences artificielles dont j'ai
parlé en intro c'est aussi ce qu'on
appelle du machine learning et c'est
comme ça qu'elles sont plus fortes que
nous parce que forcément nous on ne peut
pas analyser 15000 script pour pouvoir
en créer un ces intelligences
artificielles là elle partage une
particularité elles sont ce qu'on
appelle en anglais
narrow artificial intelligence en gros
elles sont très fortes pour faire des
tâches spécifiques men's à faire que ça
saha semble à peu près toutes les
intelligences artificielles que vous
avez croisé dans votre vie elles ont une
intelligence que je dirais verticale
dans le sens où elles peuvent creuser
qu'un aspect des choses
en français on appelle ça les
intelligences artificielles faible vous
avoue que je suis pas fan du terme
l'autre type dias et lee a qu'on va
appeler janeiro artificial intelligence
c'est une ia qu'est capable de faire des
liens entre des choses qui sont très
différentes
c'est jordi a que l'on voit dans des
films de science fiction et qui serait
doté de conscience et d'émotion en
russie n'y a qu'à une intelligence très
proche de la nôtre
cette fois je dirais qu'elles ont une
intelligence horizontal dans le sens où
elles peuvent lier différentes verticale
en français on parle d'intelligence
artificielle forte et en fait c'est ce
genre dia qu'il faut pour créer un opéra
parce que comme je vous le disais un
opéra c'est plusieurs arts à la fois
mais surtout c'est plusieurs arts à la
fois qu'ils fonctionnent ensemble et qui
se répondent chacun est au service de
l'autre c'est ce qui donne à l'opéra son
unité donc avoir plusieurs institutions
narrow intelligence
ça ne marchera pas vous aurez de la
musique avec un script peut-être une
mise en scène et des costumes mais rien
n'aura de sens rien ira ensemble car
l'ia doit comprendre que la mise en
scène doit servir la narration que les
costumes doivent servir le propos est
que la musique doit refléter l'émotion
pour ça il faut une janeiro artificial
intelligence
on en est loin très loin aux rennais
dione le directeur de l'halal institute
d'intelligence artificielle à seattle a
déclaré les technologies ont toujours
une place importante dans l'opéra à
l'opéra bastille par exemple il ya des
chariots porte des corps qui font 400
mètres carrés qui pèse 54 tonnes et qui
permet de transporter des décors de 80
tonnes cela a été fabriquée spécialement
pour l'opéra bastille et cela permet à
un technicien de changer tout seul des
décors de 80 tonnes en trois quatre
minutes
le palais garnier aussi est plein de
points techniques majeures qui était
révolutionnaire pour l'époque et on peut
donc s'attendre à ce que l'opéra
embrasse ses nouvelles technologies et
cela commence déjà l'année dernière au
palais garnier on pouvait assister aux
représentations denis de saint louis
mels un opéra ou certaines voies avaient
été traités par ordinateur
un futur très proche des humains
pourraient être assistée 10 ha pour
écrire composer à billets et mettre en
scène des opéras un fred équipe entre
nous et eux
si le sujet vous intéresse j'ai fait une
autre vidéo sur la chaîne youtube de
l'opéra de paris
c'est une vie dans un petit peu plus
sociologique qui se demandent pourquoi
y'a que les vieux qui vont à l'opéra
voilà en tout cas cette vidéo elle a été
faite évidemment partenariat avec
l'opéra de paris merci beaucoup mais ont
permis de la faire quoi et de m'avoir
donné accès à tout ça j'espère qu'elle
vous aura plu moi en tout cas ça m'a
vachement plus de la faire et on se
revoit la semaine prochaine pour une
autre vidéo
tiens